this is CES
[Music]
this year there's been a ton of
innovation in the accessibility space
we're going to look at some of the
devices made to assist with Mobility
hearing and communication difficulties
let's get into it
[Music]
first up is school it's an electric
wheelchair that can climb stairs check
this out
this is a wild
it's built with sensors that constantly
measure the ground and is supposed to
recognize obstacles and changes such as
the end of a staircase its creators hope
it'll help people move around more
efficiently and wants to bring the
device to the US
also to help with Mobility L'Oreal
created haptop it's a smart makeup
applicator for users with limited hand
and arm Mobility one in ten people in
the United States have some type of
movement disorder that doesn't allow
them to do basic functions so a lot of
people that today could not apply
lipstick on their own can now do
something very simple that can bring a
lot of confidence into their life by
using this kind of product next up
hearing these glasses can show what's
being said out loud to me
the hope is that live captions can help
people living with hearing loss but how
does it work so the glasses have
microphones built in noise canceling
microphones and they're listening and
the microphones are capturing the audio
that I'm saying
converting that audio into text right in
the glasses and then just rendering it
on the glasses I can still see
everything around me very clearly but
when I need the text when I need to
understand what someone said the words
are there for me so that's that's really
cool
drama also has an Innovative solution
for people with hearing loss it's
over-the-counter hearing aids lets you
make calls and play music
finally there are gadgets to help with
communication issues wisp is one of the
most interesting ones I saw it's
designed to amplify the voices of people
who stutter and those with vocal
disorders
I stutter myself and I suffered from
that from a childhood and especially at
high school and that's why I started my
company with speech technology is meant
for people who stutter severely people
who lost their voice so I'm about to
whisper into this thing and wisps AI
will convert that into a natural
sounding voice complete with intonations
and yeah we'll see how it works
I whispered so low that I could barely
even hear it but the algorithm was able
to bring my voice back somewhat
I'm era CVS to test and see how this
stuff works I bet you can't understand
what I'm saying that is wild one of the
most exciting things about CEs is seeing
how entrepreneurs solve problems for
people who are often overlooked for some
with the most debilitating disabilities
there might be so much more in the
future to help while all these gadgets
might not make it to the mass Market
they force you to imagine a world where
we can all do all the things we need to
do